[inaudible].
I hooks, my name is Steve Jobs are, and
this is my colleague Franz Pretorius.
We are the authors of the
little book of black holes,
which is really hot off the process
and there's some copies over there.
I hope there's a few left and we'll
be sticking around to assign a,
if you want to, um, a
version of that sign. Um,
so our book is about black holes and
about Einstein's theories of special and
general relativity.
And what I wanted to do to start is to
talk about how time behaves in special
relativity because when we get to
general relativity and black holes,
it'll help us a lot to a warmed up with
on the way special relativity works.
So,
so let's just do a first demo,
which I have to admit as a
bit of a fake, um, these, uh,
stop watching as if they
were accurate to a femto.
Second will be just right
for this Devin download, but,
but somehow I couldn't get hold of
the, the more accurate ones. Anyway,
so we're going to do the twin paradox.
I this normally understood I ain't going
to run across the room and come back.
Well France stay still and we're going
to each one of our stopwatch starting on
three, one, two, three, like this.
That's what constant velocity,
more or less book shit.
Uh, I have seven seconds, six seconds
time dilation.
I managed to have less time.
Alas,
I say just kidding because the actual
difference between our times was
approximately one,
femto second.
I'm actually now younger than
frons by about a femtosecond.
And so we commute into New York City.
We actually gain a little bit more youth
or if you maintain a regimen of jogging
every day, it does actually
keep you slightly younger. Uh,
so let's just see this same thing.
I'm in an animation I've got, um,
now, uh, me, I suppose running the other
way across the stage. Go for it. Go for,
um, holding a stopwatch, and then
I accelerated to run backward.
Meanwhile, I've got frons with
a fictitious Fred Fred here. Um,
and I suppose that I go
for a full 60 seconds,
but you can see here I've, I've, um,
arrange things so that I'm moving really
fast, which I can in the demo, I'm,
I'm, I'm moving at a significant
fraction of the speed of light.
And so my clock really does run
significantly slower. You can really,
you can really see it now on the first
thing that people tend to say when they
see the twin paradox is if,
if motion is really relative
the way Einstein taught us,
why can't we look at it another
way? Let's go to the next, um,
the next animation. Why can't we
look at it this way? Go ahead.
Where I consider myself to be stationary
and I consider France to the one who
was moving back and forth,
why can't we look at it that way?
If motion is relative and the
answer is yes, motion is relative,
but acceleration is something real.
Because when I got to the end of the room,
I had to actually work at it to turn
around and come back while as while I'm
actually moving at a constant velocity.
Okay.
If I were like frictionless or something
like that, I could just coast. Um, and,
and my, my motion would be than
physically equivalent to standing still.
So it's really the acceleration
which distinguishes between me,
the,
the guy who's clocked run slow and,
and frauds who's clock runs
at the normal time. This,
this is wall time, namely the time
that some distant observer would, uh,
would, would, would perceive, okay. So,
so let's understand a little bit more of
the physics of why time has to do this.
And the claim is that if you,
if you think about it just right,
you can not only see that time must run
slower for the accelerating observer,
you can even derive one of the main
formulas or special relativity. So let's,
let's now think about this,
this particular demo or animation
where instead of an ordinary stopwatch,
fronds and I are going to carry little
photon clocks and we measure the way time
passes according to how many times the
photon goes up and down and up and down.
And so for the moment I've got a stopwatch
also so that you can compare it and
see that these are two equivalent
ways of measuring time.
Only the stopwatch, you
know, this, this stopwatch,
who knows how that works in
might have gears or something.
The way this photon would clock works
is actually closely related to the way
atomic clocks work.
So it,
so it really is sort of physically
transparent and so far we're not having me
orphans move at all.
But now let's see indeed what happens if
I do my little dance of running across
the stage with my photon clock.
Uh,
and the claim is that my photon clock
does get out of sync with bronzes.
As you saw, the photon is
going up and down more slowly.
What's transparent about that?
Well,
let's look at two more animations
that I hope it will become clear.
I'm now going to trace the
path of the photon as it goes.
And once you can notice,
if you sort of look closely,
is that the overall
velocity of the Photon,
the overall speed is actually constant.
It changes its direction of
lost the changes direction.
And goes across and back and so forth,
but it's, it's speed is constant.
It's always a speed of light,
and as the same speed that fronds is,
photon experience was going up and down,
but Rhonda Proton makes it up and down
more times because all it's doing is
going up and down, whereas my photon
has to do the left right motion too.
And so that keeps it from going
up and down. It's been at times.
The point is that
encapsulates time dilation,
because time is nothing more than how
many times the photon goes up and down.
Nothing more or less.
So if we buy into that and we
bind to that picture, like I said,
we can actually derive one of the
main equations of special relativity.
Let's see it in the demo.
Now I'm just going to move across stage in
a, oops, we've got a little, sorry,
I forgot to reset my phone.
This is the sin of using global
variables when you should use local
because the path, is it a global
variable? Okay, nevermind.
I'm a physicist, not a computer
scientist, so I write sloppy code. Anyway.
Here's the photon. Doing what an odd to
do, following me going across the stage.
And I decided to have a similar
trajectory where I do not accelerate.
I just run in cost, block the across
the stage on. And as a result,
the photons trajectory,
my photons from directory is straight
and it follows the hypotenuse of a right
triangle.
It has a right word component where it's
going in and out of Velocity v which is
my velocity when any cross the stage,
obviously somewhat less
than the speed of light.
Although in this illustration I made it
actually nearly this because I'm like,
uh, and then, and then there's a downward
component of the photons motions,
which I defined to be c times that
time tau that I perceive as a lapsing.
This is the crucial point
that I define my time,
my proper time in terms of
how much distance the photon
managers to track in my
own friend.
Uh,
and that's why this side of the right
triangle is the speed of light times tau
on and,
and now we get to the point where we can
do just a little bit of math and come
to the punchline.
I say the Tigers,
the CRM says the sum of the squares
and the two sides of the right triangle
equals the square,
the high pod news.
Now this unknown mysterious
thing was my proper time.
We can solve this with taggers
equation for my proper time.
And you get the time dilation equation
just as Einstein derived at in 1905.
So the point that I'd like to make here,
the takeaway message is that
special relativity is simple.
Once you make the one assumption that
the speed of light is the same in all
frames as measured by
any observer provided,
they're moving at a constant velocity.
But relative to other observers,
once you make that one assumption,
just ordinary plain geometry is
sufficient to derive pretty much the whole
subject. Um, and so for
instance, in our book,
one of the things we do with
a very similar setup like
a photon clock set up is
we explain how to derive equals
mc squared with similar logic.
Now obviously you can't do that all with
plain geometry because there's a little
bit of physics and telling you what
he is and what em is and so forth.
But if you,
if you just follow your
nose in understanding what
the physics concepts are,
then a little bit of plane
geometry is enough to,
to get even into the main
depth of special relativity.
But general relativity
is quite a bit different.
And I'm going to turn it over to
France to have a first go at that.
Okay.
All right.
So now that we want to sort of ancient
need the goalies to explain with black
holes are, um, and the,
the solution that the black or solutions
that were first discovered by swatch.
So very soon after Einstein
discovered a January activity.
That's surprisingly simple. The geometry
is so incredibly beautiful and simple.
Um, but what it implies is very
bizarre and very confusing. In fact,
Einstein did not accept a lot of
the aspects of those solutions.
He never believed in black holes even
until the day he died in, in the, in 1955.
Um,
so that Steve introduced one aspect
of special relativity time dilation.
So relative motion introduces a sort of
a or observers perceived different time
based on relative motion.
So I'm going to explain one aspect or
described black holes from the perspective
of time violation. So now we have
to go to general activity. Uh,
uh, and what is new about
generativity? So as special activity,
it's a theory about space
and time or space time.
But where is in special activity?
Space Time is flat.
It's given by this Fingal them in
calcium metric. Now in January,
the tivity spacetime can be
curved and it can be dynamical.
And what produces curvature in space time
is matter and energy. So for example,
this cartoonish picture of, of the earth,
I mean the earth has a lot of matter.
It's, it's a very heavy object.
Um, and so in, in general activity,
earth is cooling space,
time around it.
And we sort of representing it here with
this, imagine the curvature of space,
time to be the surface.
And so you can sort of imagine that
the earth is denning and so the,
the earth producers curvature
in space and time. Um,
one aspect of that curvature,
sort of connecting to the time
dilation is curvature producer's time,
dilation regardless of relative motion,
something special relativity.
When we were moving relative to each
other that we perceive time dilation.
But now what the earth is doing is
if you had a clock that someone,
they're just sitting there on the surface
of the earth like we are and someone
very, very far away the clocks
near the surface of the earth.
We're run a little bit slower due
to the curvature of space time. Um,
okay. So we're going to use this ideal
that they've curvature introduces time
donations to get two black holes.
You can go to the next slide.
So to one,
as I mentioned in general activity,
it's matter and energy that produces
curvature to produce more curvature.
The theory says you need to take a certain
amount of matter and energy and make
it as dense, denser, and
denser, more compact, and
you'll produce more curvature.
So let's sort of take again,
the same idea of no till characterizing
curvature by this sort of denting the
surface and just take
a now a story or say,
imagine the sun because the sun is much,
much more massive than the earth. Um,
that 10 to the 32
kilograms and it's about a,
about a million kilometers across. Now
of course, at the surface of the sun,
there's quite a bit more curvature and so,
but more time violation than
you're at the surface of the earth.
But now our tail activity says if we
could somehow compress the sun down to a
much smaller radius, so where the surface
used to be, it will be exactly the same.
But now we're taking
all the spatter energy,
compressing it into a much smaller volume.
And so now if we get closer to
that higher curvature region,
there's going to be more time dilation
and this sort of what the sequence is
showing. Um, now a star like the sun,
when it uses up all of its nuclear fuel,
it's eventually going to go supernova.
And the core, the remnant
is going to collapse to
something called a white dwarf,
which is almost as massive as as the sun.
Um, but now it's much more compressed.
It's about the size of the few thousand
kilometers across. So of course,
near the surface of the white wolf,
there's going to be a quite a lot of
time dilation, a lot of curvature. Um,
and now we can say, oh, can
we go further? How am I,
how much time dilation in principle
could we get all four styles that are
perhaps 10 times the mass of the sun when
they go through their nuclear burning
phase? A, they sort of, they lose all
of the energy, do prevent, uh, you know,
to hold them up against gravity.
And when they collapsed down,
they won't collapse down into a white
dwarf, but to a neutron store, uh,
which is an incredibly dense object.
Again, these things weigh, you know,
round the mass of the sun.
But in typical neutron star might
be 10 to 20 kilometers in radius.
So something the mass of the sun,
you know,
compress down to something
the size of Manhattan.
It's almost absurdly
deigns to think about it.
Now for neutron stars, the curvature is
so strong near the surface of the time.
Dilation becomes, you know, significant
things that we can easily think about.
It might be a factor of 20 to 30%.
So if you were on the surface of the
nutrients story or clock would run slower
by you know, 20 to 30% compared to
someone that's far away. As I say,
Oh,
let's go further it,
we don't think that there's a form
of matter that sort of more dense the
nutrients Oswald supposedly supposedly
could contract a neutron story even
further.
Um,
like what this image is suggesting is
that the more we can sort of more we
pressurize it,
the stronger curvature becomes 60 old.
Can we compress it down to a kilometer?
Can we compress it down to the same team
leader? So the curvature becomes very,
very large and the time dilation can
become an arbitrary large factor.
And the answer is no.
You relativity something very,
very interesting happens when you try to
compress it to within what's called the
swatch sold radius of the object.
So for something like the
size of the mass of the sun,
that's about a radius of three kilometers
or them diameter of six kilometers.
So if you to try to take all of
that matter and compress it down,
when it reaches to a point of that,
that swatch total radius,
this character of space
time starts to change.
And spacetime undergoes what's
called gravitational collapse.
And surprisingly at that surface,
which isn't really a surface,
it's a place in space time. So, and
think of it as a surface. Um, it's,
we define it as a surface. It's a sphere
of a certain radius there at a time.
Dilation goes to infinity.
So if you were at that finite radius,
your clock would stop relative to
an observers that infinity. Um,
and, but, uh, you know, if you imagined,
try to compare some new that actually
it's a bit of a misnomer to think that
time is actually stopping, but
spacetime is really changing character.
The matter collapses, collapses down to
a singularity and that's a black hole.
So now you can explain,
well let me,
uh,
let me use a couple of my simple demos
to reinforce what friends are saying
about time, dilation, elation.
And what I've got here first is an
illustration of how time runs at different
elevations
and a shoretel geometry.
And this is even relevant
right here in this building.
Let's watch it again.
You see that my clock being relatively
high up in the Schwartzwald geometry runs
faster because I'm experiencing less
gravitational redshift and francaise runs
slower. But the Schwartz, you'll
geometry is really all around us.
It is an excellent approximation of the
space time geometry that we experience
above the surface of the earth.
So if this is fronds on the first floor
of this building and here we are on the
10th floor,
then it really is true that
our clock runs a little faster.
In other words,
the people on the 10th floor,
it can get more work done in the day,
but the price is the age
quicker in the process.
No free lunches.
And you see now wall clock time here
is arbitrarily distant observer and the
suction observers clock runs
even faster than mine. After all,
I am still fairly close to the horizon
and I, you know, everything is,
is so simple just because I'm not up to
drawing these beautiful funnel shapes
for firstborn child,
but it's a otherwise,
it's actually an mathematically accurate
depiction of the [inaudible], um, metric.
Now let's have one more thought experiment
where frauds and I start at the same
elevation in the Schwartzel
geometry and I jump,
but we're assuming that I'm
a tremendously good jumper.
So even though I'm close
to the black hole horizon,
I can still do it and move up
at nearly the speed of light
and then I come back down
and, and, and land. Okay, so,
so now a striking feature is that my
clock has gone through more ticks than
Francis. And if you remember that the
twin paradox that we started with,
I might seem very odd because
when we did the twin paradox,
the accelerated observed
accelerating observer, namely me,
the guy you ran across the stage and back
was the one who had fewer ticks on his
clock. But now it's, it seems like
it's the accelerating observer
and who has more ticks on his
clock that is the secret to Anon,
none of their pill.
Another pillar of relativity theory,
which is that the natural
motion of objects is the
path that maximizes the time
elapsed for that object.
So actually frauds in this animation
is doing a very unnatural thing.
He somehow hovering at a fixed
elevation in a block of old geometry.
So we have to have like a rocket ship
or asked me standing on some surface.
It's very unnatural.
Whereas I can just boost off.
And then for the entire
duration of the animation,
I am following a perfectly ballistic
trajectory with no force at all.
So most properly,
I should think of myself as the free
falling observer and France as you know,
the, the less natural observer who, who
manages therefore it is to stay younger.
Okay. And just for entertainment,
I modify this demo.
Well,
uh,
well where did they come
upstairs so that I would not stop
when I got back down to francaise level.
Um,
let's just say I keep going
toward the horizon. Okay. So, oh,
what's happening there?
Something extreme happen there.
Let's make sure it's
really clear on the screen.
MMM.
Time dilation. Got extremely intense. See,
my clock is running and running and
running and I got more texts on my clock,
but now it's consoling down tremendously.
And this is because I'm getting close
to the black hole horizon and my
gravitational red shift becomes extreme.
Okay. So then just explain a little
bit about what I mentioned before.
Um,
with the character of space time
changes completely ones as gravitational
collapse happens.
So what I mean by that
is outside a black hole,
like this spacetime is what's called
static. Um, so the pretty the,
there's a strong curvature but
it's not changing with time.
And in particular a w
one way to describe it,
if you some distance
away from the black hole,
you just experienced the same curvature.
And so let's measure distance
by radius from the black hole.
So the swatch total radius,
that's they've enterprise and see again
for something the size of the sun that
will be the radius would be about three
kilometers, three the mass of the sun.
So if you some distance away,
yeah,
you experience strong curvature but
the space time doesn't change at all.
Now if you approach the horizon and
then when you cross it spacetime changes
character completely inputting in
particular what you thought of as this
distance radius and what
you thought of as time.
The time coordinated
completely flipped character,
they completely switched roles.
And so as you cross the horizon,
spacetime suddenly becomes intrinsically
dynamical and all of space space and
time is being swept down to the
singularity or are equal zero.
And what sort of alarming about
that? Well, first of all, and that,
that's also one way to think of why the,
the, this, the surface of swa shoulder,
eight way this,
uh,
this sort of area of the swatch or radius
is nearby winterize and you can ever
go back is if we passed you date while
you can't go faster than the speed of
light. Or another way of saying that is
you only go forwards in time is a natural
direction, which is forwards and time.
And you can't go backwards in time.
So moving to like, let's say there's a
black hole over here, um, you know, I'm,
I've read our books,
I know you shouldn't cross the horizon,
but somehow accidentally wandering
across the horizon. And again,
the horizon isn't like a solid surface.
It's really just this point in space time.
And so like, oh dear, what's happened?
Well, I've gone from larger
radius to smaller radius
crossing the horizon and I'm
going forwards in time. And now I've said
suddenly when you inside the horizon,
radius is actually measuring time.
And so by continuity,
the forward direction in time
is going to smaller radius.
So suddenly once you're inside spacetime
has become dynamical in this flow of
space. Time is taking from
larger to smaller radius.
So now I panic because I heard that
there's a singularity inside the back.
One Sec.
How can I get out or getting out means
you want to go to a larger radius again
but you can because that would
mean going backwards in time.
And so you do right so big
because of the nature of time.
You can't escape the horizon. We going
out with the why. Why are you doing?
What's bad about being
caught up in this flow?
Well there's a singularity in the
geometry at what was or equal zero.
They're sort of the origin.
And again when you're outside the black
hole you can say okay our equal zero
lets aware I can avoid it.
But now you've crossover and suddenly
it's like okay where's the singularity?
What can I do to avoid it? Which
directions? Right accelerating.
But that's the wrong question anymore
because our doesn't measure radial
distance anymore.
It measures time.
And so the right question is when
is the singularity and the answer?
It's in your future.
So you can't avoid it.
And in fact it doesn't matter the guy.
So it doesn't matter which
direction you accelerating,
you're going to get to the singularity.
And in fact, uh, did this, this,
this principle that Steve mentioned
that the natural path sort of,
you maximize the time that you take.
So if you want to survive for as
long as possible, just let go.
Just relax and free, fall into
the singularity. Don't accelerate.
Okay. But um, let me
just also just mention,
this also tells us why the singularity
is such a bad thing because this,
our coordinate that outside is radius
inside this time serves two purposes.
One is it also tells you what the area
of us of a sphere is of that particular
radius, right? So it gives
you some sense of how low,
how large spaces in a certain radius.
And it's the same outside and inside.
So inside it's also measuring
the area of a sphere.
So now you cross the black hole,
you're at a certain radius.
But now time going forward
means radius decrease.
So that means space is really
collapsing down to a point.
And even worse,
what was time outside is now it's an
hour coordinate that represents distance
and that distance is being
stretched out. So this radius, uh,
there's the area of a sphere of being
squashed down to zero and the radius
diverges.
So this is the sort of spaghetti buying
singularity just by the nature of space
and time, everything gets stretched and
squeezed into an infinitely thin line.
So very, very, very bad place. Okay.
So now with, with all of that
description, you know, you say,
I that sounds bizarre,
it sounds kind of ridiculous and that's
perhaps why people like Einstein ever
really bothered to take this aspect
of the swatch old solution. Seriously.
You know,
he accepted that at describes things
far outside of bodies like the earth,
but the material in the earth means that
inside it's not the swatch or solution,
it's something different, which is
perfectly fine. Um, so he, you know,
he didn't really spend too much time
thinking about and dismissed or doesn't
physical. But then over
the last, you know, 40,
50 years essentially starting in the
sixties and seventies, um, you know,
through a combination of theory
and astronomy observations,
we started to think that they actually
are these things out there that black
holes actually might exist in the universe
that says it.
But I mean, as I've just explained,
there's a very bizarre predictions.
So you want to say if we're going to
say that there really is something so
bizarre happening out there,
that there's someplace out there with
this gravitational collapse is happening
with time completely flips,
flips on its head and drags everything
down to a singularity, you know,
to paraphrase call sake.
And it's an extraordinary claim.
We need extraordinary evidence. So
you can go to the next slide. Well,
what evidence do we have?
And I say until a couple of years ago
in Lego made their historic discovery,
which we'll talk about a little bit later.
Um,
I say the evidence was getting very, very
strong, but it was all circumstantial.
And you're a couple of examples of the,
the, the good evidence that there was,
but circumstantial.
Um,
this is a picture of looking towards
the dynamical central of our galaxy.
So it's about 30,000 light years away.
And so this is,
it's a very small frame of you,
just probably a fraction of
the Lightyear across. Um,
and this is showing that astronomers
are these bright objects here or stores.
Um,
and so it's showing an extraordinary,
over the past 20 years I've been
tracking the positions of these,
of these stores. And
you can see, well they,
they're orbiting what looks like
the dynamical centre of our galaxy,
but there's nothing there.
So they, they're Aubrey,
there's obviously something
that's keeping them in orbit.
And if you just apply Kepler's laws,
you can deduce that there
must be something there.
It's 4.4 million times
the mass of the sun.
So they're just finishing so years
something that's the mass of the sun.
It's bright.
But there is something that's 4 million
times the mass of the sun and we don't
see it. What could it possibly be? So
that doesn't show it's a black hole.
But if it were a black hole,
that would be consistent because this,
there's the radio for back all that
larger whatever radius of about 12 million
kilometers.
So in the 30,000 light years away,
it's going to be sub pixel size on that.
That is another example of the good
evidence has been gathering over the years
is in the circle of
stellar binary systems.
So this is an artist's depiction of,
uh,
the store in orbit around the putative
black hole. And again, similarly,
there's what is observed is all
the black hole is and observed,
but this story is observed. And so this
stories like wobbling back and forth in,
you know, with time, but it's
companion isn't seen. And again,
you can apply Kepler's laws and for
these stellar mass black holes in many
candidates where it's inferred that
the companion is, you know, 10, 15,
20 times the mass of the
sun. And again, the puzzle,
what could possibly be be that massive
compose the ordinary matter and that we
don't see it. So again, it's a proof that
it's a black hole, but it's consistent.
If it were a black hole, that's exactly
what we did, what it would look like.
So I think, you know, over the years
the evidence has been gathering,
but as you can see, it's circumstantial.
We're not seeing the black hole,
we seeing the effects of the black
hole and surrounding stars or,
or the story in this case. He's
now. Now that all changed, you know,
a couple of years ago and
now you've probably all seen
this IOP. But this is the,
this in fact,
this was the first gravitational waves
detected by the LIGO collaboration,
um, that represents the inspiral
and merger of two black holes.
So just to sort of briefly,
so stars can be in binary stars can
collapse. We think two black holes,
black holes can be in binaries.
So two black holes can be
orbiting each other. Uh,
if it's, uh, if you have a
single isolated black hole,
is it like from outside it's a
static space time. Nothing happens.
But if you tap two black
holes in Olberding,
you've essentially got masses in energies.
It's accelerating.
And generativity says
that when that happens,
you can actually produce
gravitational waves,
which are these ripples in the geometry
of space that propagate output at the
speed of light. So two black holes in
orbit are producing gravitational waves,
but that's carrying away energy from the
system. And so the way that that reacts,
but back on the binaries
that they spiral in.
So the system is losing energy to
gravitational waves to closer to the gate.
The fast they start to spiral,
the more they emit.
So sort of a runaway process initially
it starts out very, very slowly.
So these black holes,
poly started, you know,
formed a buy a new billions
of years before they merged,
but it slowly ramps up and,
and then it's a runaway process.
And we've seen the last few orbits of
the life of this binary as a two black
holes orbit spiraling to each
other and form a larger black hole.
Why this in terms of like showing that
this is, that calls, why it's different,
sort of qualitatively
different from before.
I said before were circumstantial
because we've seen other things,
we've seen photons and
inferring their black holes.
But here there's this patent that the
structure of the waves is really coming
from the world emotional space time
about these horizons of a black hole.
So it's really telling us what geometry
is doing in the vicinity of the horizons.
Of course,
it can't tell us what's going on inside.
So that's always going to be a
mystery if relativities right.
Nothing can escape the black or not live
in inflammation in gravitational waves.
But at least up until these new, from
outside toward, towards this point,
we've gravitational collapse
is presumably happening.
This is really a signature of what space
time is doing. Right, right, right.
At that point. So I'll briefly, um,
just in words,
describe what,
what gravitational waves are and how we,
how Lygo actually detected them.
So again,
the,
the ripples in the geometry of space
and time and they propagate outwards and
one property of their best safe.
Imagine a gravitational wave.
There's sort of moving
directly into the screen. Um,
it's changing distances because it's
a, it's a ripple in geometry. Um,
but it changes distances
in a very particular way.
So there are protocol two
polarizations one polarization.
If the gravitational wave
is moving yet one instant,
it will stretch the screen in a
horizontal direction while simultaneously
squeezing it in the vertical direction.
And as a cycle happens,
it will oscillate back,
back and forth.
So stretching and squeezing
in what's called the plastic
configuration, you know,
sort of just by the geometry.
Now the polarization is called
the cross polarization and says,
rotated by 45 degrees.
So the key thing is,
as the gravitational wave propagates,
transfers to the direction of propagation
as inducing this oscillatory change in
distance and sort of measure
of gravitational wave,
we want to measure changes in distance
as we want to construct a ruler.
It turns out that it's an incredibly
sensitive or that we have to construct.
And that's what Lygo has been
doing over the last, since the 60s.
It was planned, it's been under con
funding and construction since the 90s.
Think now,
Steve is going to demonstrate that.
Okay. So first let's see it, um,
worth yet one more animation where what
I've done is I've taken a picture of an
interferometer directly
from the Ligo collaboration.
I think this will play better. Change
the size. Okay, let's see how this goes.
Um,
so,
so first I want to show this plus
pattern of gravitational radiation,
what it would do to this device that
I'm showing on the screen if it hits the
screen justice fronds described.
So it's stretching and
squeezing the device itself.
And I tried to animate it in such a way
that that beam splitter in the middle
stays more or less stationary,
but you know what we mean by stationary
and a dynamical space time is a little
bit up for grabs anyway.
What we,
we definitely can't know is what is the
relative length of the two long arms of
the interferometer.
And the way we measure it is we have
some laser here which shoots coherent
photons.
Half of them go through the beam splitter
straight on and half of them go the
other way.
But it's a quantum phenomenon.
So really every photon
explorers both paths
the photons bounce back off the mirrors
and they recombine at the beam splitter,
each photon recombined with itself.
Because remember it explored both paths
and depending on whether those paths are
exactly the same length or
slightly different lengths,
the photon might either reinforce itself
or cancel itself out as it traveled on
to the readout device.
And, and so we have,
we have a little demonstration
scale model of Lego,
which is really working just as I showed,
let's get house lights down a little
bit on this is a little bit dim.
And the reason it's dim is that we're
using a teeny weeny little laser like a
laser pointer.
We have bigger lasers or more powerful
lasers in the physics department,
but they wouldn't let me take one,
uh, to New York City cause you know,
walk through Penn station with one of
those things and you're really taking your
chances. Okay. So, um,
so you see the, these,
these stripes are
drifting down the screen.
The reason that's happening is the
whole device is warming up a little bit.
And so all the angles and so forth
are just changing very, very slowly.
And it has nothing to do
really with the main physics.
Dylan straight the main physics
first let me block one beam.
So if I blocked one beam,
you see the stripey pattern has gone
and what's left is just some dim pattern
with a little bit of features and such,
which,
which are only have to do with the
particular optical devices that I have in
here. So you know, any flaw in the mirror
will show up as a little feature on the,
on the screen. So if I, if
I blocked the other beam,
you can see again,
the pattern goes away.
It's only when the two beams recombine
that you get this quantum year
interference between the
two just as I described.
And then it's thrown up on the screen
where the d focusing lens. Okay.
So now that the thermal expansion
has pretty much settled down,
if I juggle this thing in any way,
you can see that it, that the, uh,
interference pattern responds a lot.
And,
and the reason that it's responding is
that just a light touch on the base is
causing the relative
weight of these two arms,
this one and this one too,
to change by just enough like micron
sizes enough in order for the interference
pattern to shift by about one
stripe. So, you know, just a,
a light tap is about enough to cause
the interference pattern to tap,
to shift by, by, uh,
by one stripe. Whereas,
but like it was really seeing is it
seeing something that's more vibrational?
Like if I do this, you can see
it. It does ring a little bit.
You can see these things like that.
That is what logo is actually watching,
except they watch it a heck of a lot
better than we can watch it here with this
easy, meaty little
demonstration scale model. Um,
I can measure differences in length
of, of, of relative life in these,
in these two arms, two
about the micron scale. Uh,
Lego with a four kilometer
arms and similar light,
although far more intense,
is able to measure relative
length differences that
are less than the diameter
of a proton. So it's an school
is at least sensitive device.
I still understand that quite honestly.
Uh,
exactly all the treks that allow them
to measure things that are such small
links that are so much smaller than the
wavelength of light that they're using.
Um, so it's, it's quite an achievement
that that, as Ron's mentioned,
was decades in the making.
Um,
and there are certainly more games we
could play with this device. But let's,
let's save it until
afterward. And, and uh,
go back to the question of what are
these gravitational waves and how's the
black hole really producing?
Okay.
Right.
So it's setting the,
the next thing would
just be an animation or
sort of what it,
is that what I described.
So this is a computer simulation of
two black holes merging in there.
These are parameters that are similar
to the first event that was detected.
The so you can play it. So these are two
black holes. They're orbiting each other.
He sort of green, uh, sort
of this haze is going out.
This is a representation
of the gravitational waves.
And so what you'll notice is as they're
orbiting, the amplitude is increasing.
So that's because they actually
slowly spiraling in runaway.
The closer that they getting the
fast are they starting to move?
The more energy they mud. And eventually
it gets brighter and brighter and they,
they coalesce. When two black holes
meet, they form a larger black hole.
And then you see this little
burst of radiation at the end.
And what's left you the sort of
this perfectly stationary, uh,
rotating black hole. Um, now what,
what things do, we did a lot of things
that are fascinating about this one event.
Um, again, it represented, this is
another depiction of the way form.
So it represented sort of from the
way that Lego saw that will patent,
we can infer the properties of the,
the black holes.
They were both about 30 times.
The mass of the sun.
One's a little bit bigger
than the other one. Um,
does he slowed down tremendously. But we,
in real time, and Steve will show a demo,
which sort of almost demonstrates
at least in a second,
but if they read real realtime,
they go and get the fracture,
the sizable fraction of the speed of
light, 20, 30 times the speed of light.
And this scale is, uh, is about a
thousand kilometers for those things.
So that's incredibly fast.
And what's perhaps more astonishing is
the energy that's released in this final
final burst. Um, so it
happens in a few milliseconds.
This final boost that you saw,
um, I mean that one instant,
if you just compute the, the, the
energy and gravitational waves, uh,
it's brighter than all the visible style
out in the universe combined at one
incident. That, that sounds like a
ridiculous statement, but it's true.
So in gravity and gravitational waves
that outshines all the stars in the
universe of that one incident,
right. I think we're about
out of time, one of, yeah,
sure. That's right. So now
I think, yeah. Okay. Uh, so
this last demo is,
is aimed at showing you
analogous mechanical system.
Um, let's see if we've got this.
No, I have to restart quick
time. It always does this moment.
So what I've got is a spinning disk
which settles down to a stationary state.
It's not really quite like a,
not really quite like a black hole
merging of course with another black hole,
but it's in the same spirit
because for starters it's,
it's exhibiting similar frequencies
of output. Now for similar reasons.
No,
it looks like
I'm not going to have any
cooperation here from quick time.
One more try and then I get
to go straight to the demo.
Okay.
Recording.
There we go.
Nope.
All right. So this is nothing
more than a spinning coin.
It's called [inaudible] disk for no
good reason. It's just a spinning coin.
It's settling down and you can hear
already that it has some characteristic
frequencies.
And what we've got over here on
the right is a sound analyzer,
which is picking up everything that
this microphone hears. So, for instance,
it's hearing my voice and
if I use a tuning fork,
you can get
a peak.
You see that about 128 hertz,
let's Millie's eve. You can still see
that peak. If I, if I stopped talking,
you can see it better.
There's disk.
It takes a little while to settle down,
but in its final stages,
what I liked about it is
that it's exhibiting the same
behavior as merging black
holes in that the point of contact is
flipping around faster and faster and it's
emitting,
therefore a similar kind of Chirp only
in sound that colliding black holes in it
in gravitational radiation.
And now I'll stop talking so you can see
the wave form on the spectrum analyzer.
Okay.
Dot.
Chirp is very like the sound
of two merging black holes.
What's not so much like it is
that you see many overtones here.
You see some some down at about 30 hertz
and then all the way up to a strong one
at about a hundred to 150 that's
because it's a dirty mechanical system.
Just for contrast. Let's go back to one
of Franzia sides and you can see one,
a much more beautiful system.
These swirling block holes are,
um,
let's show it.
So this is what Lego saw.
Their picture is tilted
90 degrees from mine.
When you see this is the way form,
there's the Chirp, same chirp that I saw,
but there is no overtones because this
is a very pure tone coming from the
Claudia black holes.
But at a rather similar frequency.
You remember I was at about 150
hertz. Oh, there at about 150 hertz.
So if you could hear the black hole merge,
it would,
it would sound kind of like that.
So a great discovery.
It really convinces us that
black holes are in the universe.
And I think that's a good place to stop
for questions. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay.
I folks who have a mic here. Oh, there's
no Mike set up. So if you have questions,
I'll just pass this around.
So you told us that, uh,
close to the event horizon,
the time dilation time
runs slower compared to,
to an outside observer.
Right?
So essentially all the physical
processes at the event horizon,
car running slower,
does that apply also to the contraction?
Meaning ultimately do the black,
does the black hole actually even form
in the lifetime of the universe since the
time is essentially slowing down
to a stencil that point? Yeah.
So there's a, there's a Australia's
kind of answer to that, which is,
it depends on who's clock you're
talking about. When, when we,
when we look from outside,
as you know,
there's always a wall clock observers.
What we can definitely say is
that once a black hole is formed,
then from our perspective
as outside observers,
nothing manages to fall in.
It all kind of settles down into
the horizon, um, evermore gradually.
Um, but in terms of black
holes really forming,
that's a bit different
because the gravitational
collapse isn't complete until
it's really happened. So, so I would
say, I would say that in fact, yes,
black holes really do form. Um, it's,
it's best answered with,
you know,
with space time you have to draw something
like a pen rose diagram and say that,
that, that on any, on any
respectable time slice, yes,
there is a black hole
that really has formed.
It's just that the signals
move so strangely in the
block hole geometry that the
distant observer can never see the
signal from app or inside the horizon.
So that's, that's the way I try to
balance the two answers that, that yes,
it happens,
but you can never actually see the
signal from the black hole because that's
what a black hole is.
Hi. So you started with an
explanation of how time dilation, uh,
it depends more on acceleration than
the actual philosophy of the Observer.
But then when you got into the
Pythagorean theorem explanation,
that made perfect sense to me.
If we were just thinking about
velocity and ignoring acceleration, I,
I got a little confused about which
way I should be thinking in terms of
changing velocity or a constant
velocity and how that affects
the dilation. Yeah. The reason
for this is that it feels,
it feels more valid to compare
clocks at the same place.
So if I ran across the stage and
it's not my clock over there,
I could manage it with constant velocity,
but then you might doubt that my notion
of time over there was the same as the
one over here.
And so that's why I felt obliged to go
there and then come back a couple of
times to,
to illustrate that there is something
real going on here and that necessitates
the acceleration.
Um,
but when we get to this business
of actually deriving the formula,
then it's a heck of a lot simpler,
simpler to idealize and say, look,
this consider a perfectly
straight velocity.
What I could've done to bridge the gap
between the two is I could have said when
I get across the room,
then I turned back instantaneously
and then I would have a perfectly,
my photon will go down like this,
like I showed,
and then it would just go right back up.
So I could manage it at the
cost of infinite acceleration.
And then my geometry would
have been perfectly correct
and I would still be able
to measure at the time,
but at the same point.
Yep.
Um,
so
when we look at like atomic theory and
what Einstein and like Oppenheimer and
guys were doing with
mmm.
Like atomics,
right?
We did something with that either creating
the bomb or creating nuclear fusion
reactors.
You're talking about quantum mechanics
and even Google's exploring using that
for computation from an application
and exploitation perspective.
Has there been research into like what
we might do with this as a species or
something like that?
Does that question make sense?
The GPS answer? Yeah, you
did. You mean with uh,
black holes or with, with Caden
relativity or gravitational waves? Yeah,
gps is a good end.
Sure. Yeah. So, so, you know,
gravitational positioning satellites are
way up there and I'm in elevation and
so high above the earth that
the gravitational redshift
who fact matter and in
order to make gps work as well
as it does to within a few feet,
you have to have timing. And those
satellites figured out really well too.
I guess it's about the few
nanosecond level. Um, so,
and that's done with atomic
clocks by the way. Um,
but it was also done by understanding
this fortunate metric on now as for a
while, as for really practical
applications of black holes per se.
Well, maybe you should tell
him about the Penrose process
[inaudible] that if we did
happen to have a black hole
but came wandering nearby
and didn't sort of run into us, um, in
principle we could go, if it was rotating,
we could go to that black hole and
mine it for rotational energy. Um,
and in something that's probably one of
the most efficient forms of energy that
we could get.
Um,
if you'd think like nuclear fusion,
um,
if you think it was like the rest Mesic
Wilson of energy that you get from that,
that's less than a percent or it's like
a fraction of a percent. In theory,
if you had a very rapidly
rotating black hole,
you could get upwards of almost 30%
of its rest mass equivalent in energy
extracted from it. So, for example,
you'd be formed the black
or the mass of the sun,
there'd be a whole Solo Sun's worth
equals MC squared of energy in that black
hole. If it's rapid, the rotating
about 30% of that can be extracted. Um,
so I'm taking a third of the Sun Equals
Mc squared and converting it to energy.
Um, but yeah, that that will require
us finding one of these black holes.
And I mean they'd been,
I was a science fiction and even Freeman
Dyson had sort of imagined advanced
civilizations powering
themselves using back hauls.
Yeah.
So I have a kind of a
weird question. Um, we,
we were billions of light years away from
this collision when it happened and so
we detected it with this
exquisite detector. Um,
presumably if you were closer to
it, I mean, if you were like hosted,
what you'd be destroyed by this
enormous energetic event. I,
but there must be at some
distance where you would feel it.
What would it feel like?
That's a good gracious.
All right. I can imagine
you're going to be straight being
stretched and squeezed and let,
let's say if you're about a hundred times
a swatch or radius on this thing away.
So for this event, say you were
at about 10 kilometers away, um,
then the amplitude,
the fractional change is going to be
something like 10 to the minus three.
So you might be stretched and squeezed
by a few millimeters. So that's actually,
I think you mean you feel
it the few millimeters,
like over the length of
your bodies and too bad.
The thing where I'm a bit more concerned
about is a frequency is very high.
So this thing that I could add a hundred
hertz being stretched and squeezed it a
hundred hertz, that might mess up with
some things, but not for example. I mean,
you probably hear it like it will,
it will affect your eardrums.
There'll be stretch and
squeeze. So they'll probably
be a thing. But I mean you'd,
you'd feel it. It feels this
very rapid vibration. Um, yeah.
But the idea, you have to get very,
very, very close to it. Thanks.
I my questions about the
detection of gravitational waves.
It seems like if you kind of
rotated the instrument like 45,
if you had it originally at the ideal
angle and then you rotated 45 degrees,
you wouldn't see it at all. Maybe.
And also you were saying it like,
like the time was very short,
like if the machine had
turned off for a millisecond,
would you have just totally missed it?
And how frequently to two
rotating black holes collide?
I guess like how lucky were they that
they saw it or was it pretty likely that
they would see something?
I think it was quite like,
like one thing is we,
we didn't know how frequently these
black holes merge. This could happen.
And it was actually a lot of
doubts in the community had like,
it would actually work. So there, there's
a whole story about that that goes,
you know, it goes back
decades. Um, but you're right.
But if it had hadn't been on at that time,
we would have missed it.
And presumably these things are
happening. Um, pre, you know,
galaxy the size of the milky
way once every million years.
And so that's why Lygo has to be
sensitive enough to, at least in its,
in its range sweep up at least
about a million galaxies.
So we have a chance of seeing
like one per year, but those,
those rates are uncertain.
But you can imagine it was like hundreds
of billions of galaxies in the universe.
So every,
every day there's several dozen or several
hundreds of these mergers happening
somewhere in the universe and the
waves come, they cross you earth very,
very rapidly. So yeah, if, if I go
isn't on winter, winter passes, we've,
we've missed it. So I
think, you know, the, the,
I think we were still running at the time.
I mean,
I can take and talk about this for a
lot if he'd worries, but they're there.
It's a lot of things about this
event that was very fortunate.
The way that they're fed just
turned the instruments on.
They actually didn't think they
were ready for a science run. Um,
they didn't because of that.
They didn't fail.
It took him a long time to understand
that it really was a signal.
Someone thought they were playing a joke
or hacking the system and it took them
a long time to convince themselves and,
and this was a real signal.
And then just nature of being lucky,
like we actually didn't
expect such heavy black holes.
We had no idea about the rates.
So there was a lot of like both from
nature and the way they experiment work.
So a quick answer to this business
of being insensitive to the other
polarization.
You're quite right that if you've got
only the cross polarization when you are
ready for plus,
then you wouldn't see it.
Each detector in Ligo is sensitive
to only one polarization. However,
the signals that we can imagine
have a mix of both polarization,
both polarizations present and, and
so you're going to see it, right?
That's not a problem, right? So yes,
the intensity is going to
depend on the orientation,
but you won't miss it completely
because of that. Yeah.
So a question on that,
right?
How do we know these are actually like
black holes of binary black hole system?
And not like, you know, dilation
of spacetime eater, like
no other explanation,
right?
It's because of the very particular
shape of the wave form that there's this
what steeple? The CHIRP, right? So that
increases in amplitude reaches a maximum.
And then the case that the exact shape
is very characteristic of black holes.
So the, yeah, if you want to play
devil's advocate, you can say, well,
is there something else in the universe
that might produce this? And well,
so far we don't know.
Um,
I'd say that there's nothing that we
know of that could produce a signal like
that. Another, another side of the
question is, is it, could it be noise?
Because you know, these things,
they measuring distances,
they incredibly sensitive.
Um, so I mean, they, they,
they can detect the tiniest earthquakes
that happen anywhere in the world.
Um,
one example that they can detect just
regular waves crashing on the ocean,
on the oceans around the United States
is incredibly sensitive instrument.
So you have to also make sure that that
noise wasn't responsible for that. Um,
and that is any, that's why they actually
are two detectors. One in, uh, Hanford,
Washington state, one in Louisiana,
separated by a few thousand kilometers.
And so one reason,
well,
one way that they can vet for noise
sources is they have to see the same thing
separated by it. Most delight crossing
time. So you know, the, the, the, if the,
if the gravitational waves that
happen at a certain orientation,
they'll see it instantaneously.
The maximum time difference could be
for first hits one and then travels and
hits the other one. So the time that
light, so I think 10 milliseconds or so.
So it would be at some, some very
good questions. And that these, this
too, there's, this looks
exactly like what we,
where we solve the Einstein equations
for backup emerges as it looks exactly
like a black hole merger that they,
yeah,
those are things that need
to be considered. Cool. Thank
you. We are out of time.
So let me
[inaudible].